- OK, so I need a definitive
answer on something.
There's no wiggle room.
You gotta say right now:
Are we ever going to see you
do the Dunk Contest?
Are you enjoying L.A.?
- Yeah, it's smooth.
I'm ready to get back home, though.
- Yeah. It's funny seeing you in L.A.
because you're not like a big city
sceney mixy person.
- Nah.
I like being in the cut at the crib.
- Yeah.
- In my own bed.
- So then how do you handle, like—here,
everyone's like, “Where we at tonight?
Where the bottles? What we doin’?”
Like, how do you kind of handle
that when you know it's not really
your comfort zone?
- Stay at the crib with my peoples.
- Yeah.
- Well, lately we just been
playing Madden against each other.
So that really just kept us
out of the mix—
- Yeah.
- From being outside.
- When you play, what
team do you play with?
- The Cardinals.
- Why?
- D-Hop.
- OK. Are you all friends?
- Yeah, that's my guy. South Carolina.
- Of course. OK, are you good at Madden?
- I'mma let my fam answer that question.
- I mean, I don't really know
if that means yes or no.
- They know I'm like 15-1 right now.
So if anybody wants smoke in
Madden, just hit me up.
- Do you play anyone in the league?
- Nah, I just started playing
when we got here.
- Really?
- I kinda, I rock with it
a little bit now.
- Yeah.
So you're a week
in, and you're 15-1?
- Yeah. I'm nice like that.
- Cuz I don't think you are a gamer
or were a gamer, right?
- Nah. I mean, I play, but not as much.
I play Call of Duty.
- Yeah.
- But, like, I don't play the game,
like, every day. Probably
two or three times a week, if that.
- Yeah, and it's just caught on.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, well—
- I gotta run around with baby girl.
- Yeah. So you don't really
have time.
- Nah.
-I'm sure you miss her being here.
- Yeah, that's why I'm ready to go.
- Yeah, but I love—like, you FaceTime
her all the time.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I'm sure she—
- Or she'll FaceTime me.
- I was gonna say, she probably knows
how to work it.
- Yeah.
She knows how to hang up, everything.
- [Laughing]
- Put me on pause and say
she wanna watch TikTok.
- Oh, she's a TikToker.
- Yeah.
- What does she watch?
- She just like to dance.
So if she hear any music,
she gonna dance.
- That's really cute.
- Sometimes she'll dance without music.
She just, I guess, plays a song in her head.
- Yeah.
Well, you dance without music sometimes.
- She, she definitely gets that from you,
I would say.
- Yeah. Just be vibing, you know? Good energy.
- Well, so, like, everybody knows
you are my favorite.
You're my favorite
for a multitude of reasons.
One, because I interviewed
you, like, right before you got drafted
and you still act the exact same.
- Yeah.
- Two, because I love your dad.
That's actually my favorite
person on Earth.
You're, like, No. 2.
But a huge reason why is
you are, like, one of the most
supportive people, I think,
not even just in the league,
but just in general.
I think especially with women,
especially with Black women.
I think when people have
just kind of gone
through hard times,
you always very publicly support.
You've done it with me. You've done it
with Maria Taylor. You've done it
with Sha'Carri. You've done it with Naomi
Osaka, WNBA players.
Where does that come from for you?
Because I don't think
a lot of the guys are like that,
or a lot of guys in general.
- I can say it's just how I was
raised, you know, to
just treat everybody
how I want to be treated.
I'm a very
caring person, you
know, full of love. So
I just, you know,
spread love, positive energy.
It's pretty much me.
- Yeah.
But you do realize, like,
how much that probably means to
the people that you are doing it for.
- Yeah, 100 percent.
And now I have a,
I feel like a bigger voice.
So I feel like, you know, it—
eventually they will see
it and, you know, more people will
start doing the same.
- Mmhmm. What do you think about the way
it feels like everyone was, like,
so Team Sha'Carri, rooting for
Sha'Carri, and then she did the race
and it was like everybody
just kinda turned on her?
I mean, what was that
like for you to see online?
- I feel like that's life.
That's how it is.
Like, when you up,
everybody wanna
clap, be
your friend, you know?
But as soon as
some little thing like her
just losing a race,
they all just flipped on her.
And that's just how it is.
I feel like if she raced again
the next day and would’ve won,
they would’ve been back on,
you know, “Aw, she's the greatest.”
- Mmhmm.
- It's just, it's just life.
I like how she dealt with it, but
she's gotta come back
and redeem herself.
- The thing that was so puzzling to me
about that whole thing is
everyone's like, “She's too cocky.”
Like, well, no. She just thought
she was gonna win.
- Yeah, I feel like she's not cocky.
I just feel like she's just got
a lot of confidence in herself.
- Mmhmm.
- I feel like it's the same with me.
Like, I'm not cocky at all.
Very humble, but I'm confident too.
- Yeah.
- So if I feel like, you know, I'm
the best, I'mma say that.
- Yeah.
- So I feel like that's
just what she was doing.
- One thing I always remember
when Michael Jordan, you know,
did “The Last Dance”—everybody's
watching it over the pandemic—
he was talking about a player.
I can't remember who, but he was like,
“I respect this player
because he was still talking trash
while he was losing.”
- Yeah.
- Like, he stayed consistent.
He stayed the same with it.
And I actually think it's, like,
a sign of strength and a sign of, like,
really knowing who you are that
even at the end of the race,
she was like, “I'm
gonna come back.”
- Yeah.
- It's like people want to see somebody
be defeated when they are defeated.
- Yeah.
- And I don't really know what,
like, people get from that,
especially online.
- I don't either, honestly.
- Yeah.
- I'm with that,
you know, staying
consistent no matter
if you winning or losing.
So back to saying,
like, I like how she dealt with it.
Like, right after she was like,
“You know, I'll be back.”
Like, “Just gotta put in
more work.”
- Yeah.
- Just simple as that.
- Totally.
Now, you are someone who loves
to engage on Twitter.
- [Laughing]
- You will talk to the fans.
I think at one point in
a postgame interview, you were like,
“That was for you who said
we weren't gonna win this!”
- Yep.
- So tell me that story, and
what happened with that tweet?
- It's pretty much just, you know, it'd
be a lot of talking I'll be seeing.
It really be my mom.
She'd be trying to
get me off of Twitter all the time.
Like, don't even, don't
even go on Twitter.
Don't look at your phone like that.
No, I was just looking,
and I just, you know, I be seeing people
talking all the time
before games, after games.
And I normally don't
say too much before.
Sometimes I want to, but
I'll be like,
“Nah, we gotta lock in on the game.”
Like, you know, just let the win
do the talking or whatever.
So then after the fact,
if we win, now
I can say whatever I want.
- Yeah.
- So just, like,
they go on there and talk,
I'mma talk back.
So if anybody @ me,
better be prepared for a reply.
- “Better be prepared
for that postgame interview.
I'm calling out your @ name!”
- Yup.
- So get ready for the tweets.
- And all my fans,
I'mma make sure they get in all
your mentions, replies, everything.
DMs, I'mma make sure they all DM you.
- All of it. All of it.
I know. OK, so for me, I remember
when I first started in my career,
to be completely honest, I, like,
really cared about social media.
- Yeah.
- Like, I really cared about what someone
was tweeting about me or commenting.
You reach a point
where, like, you stop caring, right?
But I think that
when there's so many people
always saying things about you, it's
hard to completely block it off.
- Yeah.
- Are there times that it does
somewhat get to you, or
are you completely
used to it at this point?
- I feel like sometimes,
you know, like, it gets under my skin.
So that's when I'll say something.
- Mmhmm.
- But most of the time
I'll just be cool. And, like, it's hard
to not see everything.
Like, even on my Twitter,
if I scroll for a minute,
it'll have, like,
"Ja Morant" right there,
and it'll just show all the tweets
that got my name in it.
So, like—
- OK.
- I don't know how to get away from that.
So, like, I'mma eventually,
you know, see the tweet or whatever.
But, like, no, I really don't care.
I feel like now social media
is just brainwashing people
- Mmhmm.
- Like, people living lives, you know,
they're not
living in real life.
- Yeah.
- They just go on there
just to say something
negative just to
get attention, so.
- And like, why not be nice?
- Yeah.
- I'm like, "Everyone should just be nice
to everyone all the time."
Like, what do you get out of
being mean to somebody online?
Like, I just—I don't understand.
Like, what would be the point
of making a comment
that is at least neutral, right?
- Yeah.
- Like, it's OK to say, "OK,
I don't think you had a great game."
That's fine.
- Yeah.
- But, like, I just think sometimes people
tend to take it to another level
that it just, like, doesn't
really have to go.
- Yeah, like,
you see some players get,
you know, death threats
and all this stuff.
Like, nah, that's too far.
- Yeah. No, totally.
Absolutely. I mean, that's
actually life. Like,
there's no place in the world
where, like, things
don't have real consequences
except for online.
- Yeah.
- And so I just think at some point
there is gonna be this awakening
for people that decide that's
what they, what they wanna do online.
- They behind a phone
so they feel like
they can say whatever.
- Yeah.
- I doubt most of ‘em say it in person.
- Yeah. No, like, 100 percent.
Nobody would say it in person.
- They won't.
- Yeah. I mean, so
speaking of, you know,
just absolutely unacceptable things,
I know obviously in Utah,
your family was unfortunately subject
to, like, a terrible,
racist incident there.
I know that your dad has spoke on it,
but I just wanna know, for you,
what was that like,
and what was the timeline from
when you, like, realized what happened?
Cuz obviously you were
playing a game—a great game,
by the way—that kinda ended up
being marred by this happening.
- Oh, I feel like, you know,
it was tougher for me.
Like, every game,
I know where my people sittin' at,
no matter if we home or away.
Like, I ask where they
sittin' at before the game
so I can look.
Sometimes my mom will wave
and just be like, "Let's go."
My pops is normally courtside.
But, you know, we was away.
I put 'em all in
the same section
for that reason,
you know, hearing about
how Utah fans were.
And I mean, I was—I think it was
second half. I was
scoring—like, I think I scored,
like, back-to-back,
or there was a timeout.
And, like, I just went to look up,
and I just see, like,
my whole family standing up.
And then I knew at that point
it was, you know, something.
So, like, I'm trying to look back,
but I'm like, "Bruh,
I gotta lock into the game."
But my loyalty, like—
I felt like if anything had to happen,
I would probably end up
in the bleachers, so I was just trying
to just tell
our security, like,
"Just tell them to just stop and chill."
But at that time,
I didn't know what was going on.
So, I mean, it was—I felt like,
you know, my peoples was like,
"Ja, it's easy for you
to say to calm down,
but you don't know
what's going on," or whatever.
And then they finally told me
after, and I was like,
"Wow, I wish I told y'all
to just, you know,
go ahead and handle
y'all business, cuz—"
- Yeah.
It's funny cuz
that's what everyone says.
They're like, "Listen,
it reaches a point
where disrespect is disrespect."
- Yeah.
- And, like, me—like, my whole family,
you know, they'll laugh and joke.
Like, we all good people.
Like—
- Y'all are.
- Even if we met you
for five minutes, like,
we gonna treat you like,
you know, we knew you for a while,
laughing and joking.
And if you see any of my family
get to that point,
obviously they fed up, so.
- Yeah.
It feels like lucky—
luckily, there has been, you know, a crackdown
on what is going to be
acceptable for NBA fans.
But why do you think fans
even feel like they could have acted
that way to begin with?
- I honestly don't know.
I feel like my fam
laughing and joking, obviously, but
they just as confidence—
confident in me as I am.
So I'm pretty sure they was like,
"Oh, here he go." Like, "He waking up,"
and they probably
just started getting mad
cuz we was coming back.
- Nah, you was big wakin' up.
I think that was
47 points in that game.
- So, I mean, honestly, I don't know.
I just feel like,
you know, they feel like they can
get away with a lotta stuff.
- Mmhmm.
- And most of the time,
if it's an incident
where it's a fan and a player,
normally the player,
you know, the one that get punished,
get all the attention.
So I feel like they just
felt like they would have
got away with it.
Utah definitely,
when we came back, you know,
showed us a lotta love.
So we appreciate that.
- Yeah. There was a really beautiful
moment between your dad and Donovan.
- Yeah.
- And I know Donovan very publicly on
Twitter was like: "This is wrong.
This is unacceptable."
Like: "We're all humans."
We're just trying to play this game.”
So it was really nice to see your dad
say: "Listen, you're great.
I'm happy you did that. I'm
rooting for y'all."
- Yeah.
- What was kind of
the inception of that moment?
And did you get to talk to Donovan
and your family get to talk to him one-on-one?
- Yeah, I talked to a couple
of players on their team.
Even when they came to us for Game
3, me, like, on my pregame shooting,
a lotta players came up to me
and apologized for what happened.
- That's great, yeah.
- So I—like I appreciated that. And
my parents obviously wasn't at the,
you know, pregame stuff.
So that was really like
the first time they
came in contact with a player.
- Mmhmm.
- And Donovan, you know,
sent me a personal message
to me
and my family and then was
able to talk to my dad.
And like I said, like,
we show everybody love.
We treat everybody the same.
And that's just
the type of people we are.
You know, my dad said
even though, like, we lost,
he hope they go all the way
and win it just for
what they've been doing, so.
- Yeah. No, I love that video.
- Yeah.
- It's so good. It's so good.
OK, so I need a definitive
answer on something.
There's no wiggle room.
You gotta say right now:
Are we ever going to
see you do the Dunk Contest?
[Laughing]
- I don't think so.
- Really?
- Now, OK, so we've had conversations
about the Dunk Contest,
and I know your biggest thing is
about the judging of the Dunk Contest.
- [Laughing]
- So what would it take
for you to be like, "OK,
you know what? I will do this"?
- A million dollars.
- Best dunk gets a mil.
- They give me a mil,
and I'll get in the Dunk Contest.
So until then, I'll be watching
and just
sending my tweets out for the
judging and stuff.
But I feel like now, you know,
you just see so many,
like, crazy dunks in-game
that when the Dunk Contest
come, you just,
you don't appreciate the dunk as much.
And not too many people can do
the dunks guys
are doing in that Dunk Contest.
- Mmhmm.
- So I feel like if you look at it
that way, it'll be a lot
more, you know, 50s.
-Yeah.
At what point did you change
your mind, though?
Because there was a time
you were like: "Dunk Contest is great.
I'd love to do it one day."
Then I just think you were
kinda watching.
You were like, "All right, maybe not." Like,
when did that shift happen?
- The judging. Like, the past,
you know, two years,
I was like: "Nah. Can't do it."
- How would you judge it? If you got to—
if you decided how they were judged,
who'd judge it, all that stuff,
tell me what your format
would be for that.
- I probably would still do,
like, the
former players to judge.
But I just feel like, you know,
you just gotta look at it as,
how many people can
actually do this dunk?
Or, like, how difficult was it
to, you know, do this dunk?
Cuz even though,
like, you have somebody
made the dunk
look easy, it's not.
Like, it's times where
like, I'd be in the gym,
trying some of the dunks
and be like, "Bro, like, it took me
10 times just to"—like, and they go
make it on their first time.
So I feel like they look at it
as, "Nah, that was too easy for him,"
but not looking at the actual dunk.
So they'll be like,
"All right, this an eight,"
when it should be a 10, you know?
- Mmhmm.
Like, they actually
just made it look easy.
- Yeah.
- And that's why they should get the 10. Yeah.
- Yeah, that's exactly why,
especially if you doin'
between-the-legs backwards. Like,
same foot, same hand, between—like,
you don't see people
doing that all the time, so.
- Mmhmm.
If you did the Dunk Contest,
in this fictional world,
tell me three players
that you think would give you,
like, the best run for your money.
Like, the best competition for you
in that Dunk Contest.
- Zach LaVine. Aaron Gordon.
And I'm kinda in a tossup between
Derrick Jones Jr. and Zion.
- OK.
- Yeah.
- That would be a fun one.
- Hey, maybe one day. Maybe one day
they fix the judging
and they get the competition.
We can make this work,
NBA. We could do it.
You've obviously
had a lotta great in-game dunks.
Who do you wanna dunk on
that you have not dunked on yet?
- LeBron.
- Yeah, for sure.
- I'd probably get that poster
and, like, just put it
soon as you walk in my house, right?
I'd probably have it all over the wall.
- You open the door—
- Like, just cuz it's LeBron, like—
- Yeah.
- Even—I remember
watching when Tatum
actually dunked on him.
Like, I don't know what
I would have done in that moment
cuz, like, I can do a regular dunk
and I'll be screaming
for about three or four seconds
and be behind the play.
So, like, if I actually, like,
dunk on LeBron,
like, I probably would get a tech.
- You just won't be able to handle it.
- Yeah. Like, it's LeBron.
Like, not even on, like,
big fan—like, I'm a fan of his
game and it's Bron.
But who wouldn't
wanna dunk on LeBron?
- Yeah.
- Like, that's saying
like back in the day,
like, who wouldn't
wanna dunk on Jordan? Like—
- Mmhmm.
It's gon’ happen one day. - That's something
you can tell your kid about, be
like,
“Kaari, you know I dunked on LeBron
or Jordan, right?”
She probably don't know who
they is right now, but—
- She gonna pull up the tape.
- Yeah.
- That’s the photo
that's behind us on the wall.
Tell me about kind of like
the anatomy of a dunk, right?
Like, for example, how did you know
you could jump over Kevin Love?
Like, at what point are you like,
“All right, I can make this work”?
- I think it was like a—
I think if I remember the play right,
I think Dillon was dribbling
and, like, the ball kicked off his foot.
So when I picked it up,
a lot of the Cavs players
were, like, chasing after the ball.
But I picked it up and then all I seen
was the goal, really, honestly.
And then I went to,
you know, just like,
all right, well, it's time to dunk.
And then Kevin Love
was right there. So I'm like,
well, it's too late
to try to do something now.
Like, I can't just jump
and then come down
like, nah, never mind,
I ain't trying to dunk.
So I just, I tried it.
- Yeah.
- I end up clearing him,
but I tried to dunk the ball too hard,
hit the back rim.
- But even your missed dunks
are like works of art.
Like, they still look pretty good.
- I think I'm more known for missing
dunks than making them right now.
My comments be like
"Make a dunk," or people would be like
"Land on two legs."
Like, bro, do you know how hard it is
to try to do that every time?
- Yeah.
- I be wanting to comment
and be like, "You know there's
other players landing the same way
I'm landing, right?" Like,
I can try to control it,
but it don't work every time.
- Yeah.
Why do you think your dunks look
so cool, though?
Like, I saw those photos
that you retweeted
where it's two different games,
but it's, like, the exact same.
I'm like, how does
that happen?
- Probably a turnover.
I'll be thirsty on fast breaks. Like,
I don't know. I turn into
the fastest player ever.
Just run down the court
looking for the dunk.
- Yeah.
- Even on that picture,
I think it was versus the Mavs—
I’d have to pull the video up—
but when Kyle passed it
and I dunked it,
he was like, "Dang, 12, you thirsty"
when we was running back.
And I was laughing at him,
but, like, I just take off running.
And I just try to
kinda play, like, cat and mouse.
Like, if I know I have people
ahead of me,
I, like, run slow so the defense will
try to, you know, go to them.
And then I just come shooting
straight down the middle.
And I think both of those dunks
was, like, the same play.
- OK.
- But just different games. Yeah.
- Are you, for the person that's, like,
getting dunked on,
are you a believer
in, OK, make the business decision
and get out the way
or, like, try to stop the dunk?
- Nah, I'mma get out the way.
- Like, I don't
wanna be in the picture.
- I'm 6'3", 175 soaking wet.
Like, what I look like trying to jump
with somebody like that.
I'mma just swipe and just move out
the way, like, “You got it.”
Hopefully I just
tip the ball before they go up,
but I think I've been dunked
on a couple of times before.
- Yeah.
- That's why I—
- It comes for everybody.
- I wanna dunk on people that
I know, like—once I dunk on somebody,
like, that feeling of trying
to get the ball out fast and, you know,
I don't wanna be one of them.
So I'mma just swipe.
Sometimes I might try you, though. If I,
if I jump before you, I'm—
if I can jump before
you, I'mma try to block it.
- Yeah.
- But if you already on your
gather step, you got it.
- Best of luck. Yeah.
- Yeah, you got it.
- Continue on.
- I might just push
you up like, “Go ahead.”
- I remember in the press conference
in the bubble after your rookie
season, I asked what you will remember
most about that year, and your answer
was not making the playoffs.
What will you remember
the most about this past season?
- Similar answer. You know,
making the playoffs but
not getting farther.
It's just, you know—I feel like
we showed
we're one of the
top teams in this league.
We can play with the top teams
in this league. I feel like
just our experience and
just jelling together
kinda played a factor in it.
But obviously we still fought
throughout the series, but,
um, I really just love, like,
both years. Even though, like, we lost,
we all still had the same mindset of,
you know, well, we gotta work.
So after we
didn't make it the first year,
we was like, we gotta lock
in this offseason
and make it next year. And we did.
So now it's the next step, which is
getting farther and
trying to actually
win a championship.
- Mmhmm.
- I feel like this year,
guys have been together
a lot in the gym together,
which is, I feel like is
good for us with our chemistry.
And we just gotta continue
to come together as one.
- Mmhmm. And one thing I think
every NBA fan realized about
the Grizzlies is y'all
do not give up.
- Yeah.
- Like, there is so much fight, and y'all
seem like y'all are never dead.
- Yeah.
- It's like you cannot
even take your foot off
the gas a little bit
because y'all will come back.
- Yeah.
- I mean, where does
that come from for you guys?
- I just feel like
we have the right pieces around us.
I feel like we all kinda
the same with that
underdog mindset.
You know, never satisfied.
Like, it's times like we can win
a game, you know, we'll still be
frustrated with how we played
cuz we know, all right, this game wasn't
even supposed to be that close.
- Yeah.
- We just never satisfied.
We always wanna get better.
And that's just our mentality
to go out there and
just play hard, like, no matter
the outcome. Play as hard as we can
And just continue to fight,
you know, till that
last buzzer sounds.
So, each and every game,
that's just how we attack it.
- Mmhmm. Yeah, cuz I think
during the playoffs,
there were times people were, like,
counting you guys out.
- Yeah.
- And you were always, like,
no, we're gonna come back.
- Yeah.
- We're gonna figure it out.
We're gonna always put up a fight,
always give you a good performance.
And you guys definitely did that.
Speaking of being counted out,
you talked about it
a bit: the Olympics.
How you feel about
the Olympics right now?
You know, I'm happy
those guys was able to win.
That's big time.
I actually watched that game.
- Yeah.
- That was really
the only game I watched.
You know, I sent out tweets,
like, asking what was happening.
People thought,
you know, I was trying to be funny,
but I really wasn't watching.
Like, I was trying to figure out—
I just seen USA this, USA that.
And I'm like, all right,
so what's going on?
Like—and it's like, all right,
they lost this game.
They lost this game.
And that really was the main topic
when they was losing.
If it was games they was winning,
and you'd just be like, all right,
they won this game
and nobody said nothing else.
- Mmhmm.
- Like,
feel like that's just how it is now.
But, you know, a
lotta people was trying to, you know,
make it out like I was trying to
dis the USA team and stuff.
But it wasn't that.
- Good.
- Like, me, I'mma speak my mind.
I'mma tell you
exactly how I feel. So, if
I wanted to say something about 'em,
I woulda put the @ on there.
- Yeah.
- Like, @USA, you this. Like, I wouldn't—
- @USA.
- Yeah. Like, I wouldn't—
- Yeah.
- I wouldn't even sugarcoat
it or try to, you know,
talk behind their back
or nothing like that.
- Yeah.
- I was just really trying
to figure out, you know,
what was going on.
- Yeah, for sure.
And I know you were, like, really happy
when they won.
And it was definitely a good game.
Is playing in the Olympics
a goal of yours?
- Yeah, for sure.
- Yeah.
- Definitely is.
- Were you, like, upset or hurt
that it wasn't this time around?
- Nah, not really. I wasn't—
I mean, I'm grateful and thankful
for everything. I know, like,
it's all God's timing.
- Mmhmm.
- So, whenever my time comes,
you know, I'll be ready.
I just took
this offseason
for a time for me to, you know,
just continue to
get better in all areas of my game, so—
- Mmhmm.
- I wasn't, you know,
too much pressed on none of that.
- Yeah.
So, we're kind of in a moment
in the NBA where it's like
a transition. The new young guys
are becoming the stars,
and then pretty soon the older
guys are gonna kinda phase out.
Is that what you feel right now
as someone in the league,
that this is kind of like the new age?
- Yeah. I feel like, you know,
we have a lot of talent.
Any time you mention,
you know, guys under 25, there's
a lotta guys
you can name. Exactly why
I'm not about to name
everybody right now
cuz then they’ll be like,
"Oh, you forgot this person."
But—
- Yeah.
- I feel like the league is in very good
hands with the guys under 25
who are rising to be
the superstars in this league.
- What do you think is the difference
between a star and a superstar?
- I feel like
you have some guys who are
capable of being
some of the top players
in this league. It's just
certain little things,
like, superstars do.
- Mmhmm.
- Like, if you mention, like,
Kobe, Bron, like, all those guys
just have a
a different edge. KD.
- Mmhmm.
- I feel like
they just do what superstars do,
whether it's
taking on whatever challenge,
bringing their team back,
icing the game for their team.
You know, certain stuff like that.
Not saying it's like
some stars who can't do it.
It's just, it's a difference.
- Yeah.
- It's a difference.
- It's like this thing
you can't really put your finger on,
but you just know it kinda when you see it.
- Yeah. Yeah. Like, all right, he's a star,
but this guy right
here is a superstar.
Like, you just know
the difference.
- Yeah.
So, when we were talking about
how you would love to, you
know, one day dunk on LeBron
or like when people talk about,
you know, dunking on Jordan,
who do you think of this wave
is gonna be that guy
where people talk about him as, like,
almost the standard?
- I'mma say me. I just have
that confidence in myself.
- I knew you were gonna say you.
I should've said you can't say you.
I should've said
you're not allowed to do that.
But I mean, I think that—
that's the thing.
So, when someone asks someone
a question like that
and then they say themselves,
everyone's like, "Oh, my God,
they said themselves.
I can't believe they would do that."
But why would you not say yourself?
- Yeah.
- Like, that's the point.
- Me personally,
I’ll never say nobody
in this world can beat me
one-on-one, better than me.
- Mmhmm.
- Like, it's just that confidence
I have in myself.
- Mmhmm.
- And no matter, you know, who
I'm going up against,
I'mma always take myself. Like,
I don't fear nobody.
So, I mean, everybody, like
I've been saying, put on their shoes
and stuff the same way I do.
- Yeah.
- So,
no point in, you know, being
scared of somebody out there.
I'm taking me and doubling
down every time.
- Yeah. As you should. As you should.
One last thing I wanted
to talk to you about,
because we touched on it
a bit with the article
that I did with GQ
and I had interviewed you for that.
- 42.
- Very cute. You had your bottle of 42.
Everybody, that's Ja's favorite drink.
You ever wanna get him anything,
get him a bottle of 1942.
- 1942.
- Cuz you had your 21st birthday in the bubble.
- In the bubble, yeah.
- And, like, they threw a little party for
you.
- 42 was on deck.
- Yeah, 42 was a thing.
And then you very recently
turned 22.
Happy late birthday.
I remember the days.
- Thank you.
- Enjoy being 22.
But no, in the bubble,
one thing you were talking about was
how really difficult it was for you
at times.
- Yeah.
- Like, it was difficult for, really, most people.
And you said that you went through
a lot of mental issues there
but nobody really knew.
- Yeah.
- Can you kind of elaborate on
what it looked like for you mentally?
- Me, like, I'm a big family person.
So, you know, being away
from my family, obviously,
was tough on me.
Any time everybody
asks me, like,
"What's your hobbies off the court?"
Like, that's my hobbies. You know,
spending time with my family.
We’ll find something
to do. Like, it don't matter what.
Like here, we all just started
just playing Madden just
to, you know, just bond.
Like, we just sit outside,
play a game, and
we're just very competitive.
But being in that bubble,
you know, I wasn't able to do that.
I had to talk to all my family
through FaceTime,
which was—you know, it's
not a bad thing, but it was tough
not actually seeing them.
I had a daughter. Couldn't even see her.
Trying to talk to her
through FaceTime, and,
I don't know, I just felt like
the bubble just wasn't me. Like,
obviously I'm a homebody.
I like being at home, but
just being stuck in there
and not being able to do nothing
was kind of tough, like—
I was just overthinking a lot.
I was, you know, getting down.
But I don't tell nobody
none of that stuff.
Like I just—anytime
somebody asks me, like, "Are you OK?"
I'm gonna always say, "I'm good,"
even if I'm not. I'm
just kinda used to
getting through stuff on my own.
So it was definitely tough for me.
- Yeah.
- Not saying I was ready to leave the bubble, but I was.
I mean, everyone was.
Everyone was ready to go.
But I mean, is that difficult,
like, to know that
even if you're not OK,
you're saying you are.
And then it's like, OK, well,
when you're not OK,
what do you do? Who do you talk to?
What—it feels like—
- It's not, it’s not—I feel like the world now,
people say it's toxic.
I feel like it is. Like cuz,
it can go either way.
Like, you know, you
probably can get through it, or you can
go down even more.
I always say—like,
one of my favorite quotes was,
you don't realize you're drowning
when you're trying to be
everyone else's anchor.
So, like through the bubble
I was
just thinking about that quote, like,
you know, sometimes you gotta
put yourself first. Like
your health. No matter what it is. Like,
I'm always making
sure everybody else straight,
but sometimes I gotta
worry about me.
And normally that's the times
when I
be in a dark place,
when I'm trying to make sure
everybody else good, knowing I'm
not good and it just be even more,
you know, harder, so.
- Yeah. That's one of the things
I felt like they tried to do
well in the bubble was,
you know how when you would wake up,
you would have to do the questionnaire?
And, like, the very last question,
they say is, like, “Do you wanna speak
to a mental health professional today?”
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And I thought that was like
a really nice thing that they did
because it was hard
for so many people.
And when I've done interviews,
I talk about it.
I talked to Jimmy Butler about therapy.
I just talked to Michael B.
Jordan about therapy.
And they've all said, like,
"I have tried this,
and it has helped me."
Michael B. said that he still does it.
- Yeah.
- Is that something that you would try?
I think, you know, eventually I would.
Normally, like I'm just so used to
either getting through it myself
or just talking to my fam. Or, like,
my close people.
Like, I don't trust a lotta people, you know,
with certain stuff.
So I feel like that's
why I haven't yet.
- Mmhmm.
- But I mean, right now
I feel like
my life is good.
- Totally.
- I'm happy.
I'm enjoying it.
Just gotta stay right there, you know?
- Yes.
That's what I was gonna say.
You always have a smile on your face.
- Yeah, I'm always smiling.
It's a lot behind a smile,
but right now it's all smiles.
- Good.
No, I'm glad. Cuz like, I guess—
you know, everybody always be like,
"She only wanna talk about when
Ja's doing well."
I'm like, "Yeah, I do.
He's my favorite."
But no. So I'm so happy
you were able to come on and do this.
But tell me, like,
what's the biggest jump
you're gonna make next season?
What are we gonna see from Ja?
- I'm trying to be an All-
Star, All-NBA team,
and I'm trying to win a championship.
- Mmhmm.
- That's my three goals right there.
- Speak it.
Speak it.
- Yeah.
- And then maybe with some
tweaks...win the Dunk Contest?
We'll see.
- We'll see. Stay tuned.
I'mma keep trying.
- Stay tuned.
But no. Thank for your time.
You were fantastic, as always.
Hair has grown exponentially
since the first time I met you.
- Man, I need to get it done.
I look rough on camera right now.
I hope y'all can, you know, put
a lil’ filter or something on me, man.
- A lil’ Photoshop?
- Yeah.
- Thank you, Ja.
- You got me?
You got me, right? All right. We're good.
- Thank you.
- No problem.